part of the reason the the crisis
refugees arm especially for talking
about Syrian refugees is complicated has
a lot to do with our role in Iraq and
Afghanistan it has a lot to do with that
the birth of Isis has a lot to do with
our role in Iraq and Afghanistan and and
and all of these like prisoners of war
that we kept you know a lot in prisons
in these countries who had the time to
to to plot and think and plan on a
larger scale and and then the people
that we funded the weapons that we left
the money that we that we spend arm in
the same way that that people like Osama
bin Laden used to be on an American
Payroll in many ways this is some of our
own stuff coming back to to haunt it's
not just Americans of course because
we're talking about you know a global
crisis so to speak arm it's very obvious
why people want to leave Syria I know
it's very confusing about whether you
know we should be giving Assad money or
which we should be backing whom or what
have you it's complicated because of the
underhanded way in which we have played
the game the number of assassinations
that US money has been behind the the
number of you know of rebel groups that
we have supported that AB at some point
turned on or against our interests or
our best interests or against human
interests when you play the game that
way that's what happens so what do I
think about that side of it that's what
I think I think it's what do you expect
now in terms of people accepting and
embracing refugees yeah it has to happen
I mean that for example is some I mean I
think Barack has agreed to accept like
10,000 over the next two years
I mean that's what America is founded on
of course when you look at Europe
Germany it's it's impossible to not go
back to World War two it's impossible to
not look at the fact that you know
Germany is the superpower that they are
right now and their role in the euro has
a lot to do with the fact that because
they were not allowed to have an army
they were able to invest in other things
and to develop other things which gave
them an economic stronghold that we now
see them maneuvering I look at that
800,000 people that will be accepted
into Germany and I think of the victims
of the Holocaust and I go okay well
these many people were exterminated
these many people are now going to be
accepted i know i'm connecting weird
dots here but hey I think I think it's
weirder to try to disconnect these dots
you know look at the irony all the other
countries they're taking like 24,000
France has taken twenty four thousand
other countries 22-24 Germany 800,000
you know which fills a big gap right of
course what we're going to see there and
what we could learn from is that that
economy is going to grow and blossom but
as a result of the ingestion of those
people and that's something that we
always tend to forget is that with you
know the arrival of new people new
energy there's always new businesses new
markets and new things that occur it's
not just unemployment people want to
work actually people want to work the
reason why America is in the position
that it is is because of all of the
because of its diversity not because of
the smart men who look alike who run it
but because of the diversity of the
people
it's because of the diversity of the
people that all of these things you know
i have taken rude and that we've been
able to blossom the way that we have and
the pushback is ludicrous